so you really have to see this video of
a fox news host admitting that
conservatives are total and complete
hypocrites and many times I've said if
Obama did this if Hillary did this they
wouldn't just be calling for their
impeachment they'd be calling for their
heads example if Chelsea Clinton had 5%
of the role that Ivanka Trump has had in
the Trump administration if Chelsea was
sitting with other world leaders at the
g20 sitting in for our Secretary of
State FoxNews would be 24/7 demanding
hillary clinton be tarred and feathered
if obama at a press briefing played a
five-minute propaganda video like donald
trump did on monday this week during a
hundred year pandemic they would be
calling for Barack Obama's head and when
Trump has now gone full authoritarian
claiming that he has the absolute
authority to open or close a state at
his demand that governors must do what
he says any supposedly small government
conservative who believes in states
rights or federalism and the
Constitution and says nothing is a
gigantic glaring hypocrite and Brett
Bayer on Fox News called it out some Fox
News people like britt hume have been
sort of just waving off trump's
growingly a growing belligerent
authoritarianism but brett bayer admits
it so good for Brett check this out
brett is asked how do you see the battle
between Trump and governors going in the
future over over this issue of opening
and closing states here is what brett
bayer says how do you see this shaping
up across the country with the president
with his fiery statements last night and
the governor's trying to pour a little
cool water on it first of all the
Constitution is pretty clear and the
constitutional scholars will say that
this is not the president flicking on
the switch it's the governor's and the
local authorities that have that going
forward I think that there's a POC recei
here in that you know one if President
Obama had said those words that you
heard from President Trump that the the
authority is total with the presidency
you know conservatives heads would have
exploded
across the board to a week ago there was
a lot of coverage of saying why isn't
there a national stay-at-home order the
Constitution is clear Trump doesn't have
the authority the governors have the
authority that's the correct analysis
but Brett goes into the hypocrisy which
is what I like if Obama ever said
something like this right-wingers would
be slamming Obama's authoritarian
one-world government whatever and in
fact many of them were calling Barack
Obama a dictator anyway they're silent
right now and Trump is increasingly you
know the the the the things that Obama
was accused of being Trump increasingly
is and very few people are actually
calling it out so of course you know
disclaimer one moment of truth and
clarity on Fox does not change that they
continue to big-picture be water
carriers for the disinformation of Trump
through the corona virus pandemic but
here's the really scary thing about Fox
News to me if they are successfully able
to spin this presidency into something
that maintains 40 percent support for
Donald Trump they can spin anything to
40% support and what I mean by that is
this is by far the most outrageous
presidency we've had in the modern media
era george w bush was a disaster he was
a war monger i'm not praising george w
bush but george w bush was much more of
a standard of right winger and the right
wing media playbook for how to defend a
standard right winger is very
well-written there was nothing new there
we know that that will have roughly 40
percent support foxnews has been able to
evolve on the fly and figure out how do
we defend anything donald trump does and
if they can do it with trump and keep
them at 40 percent support i fear that
there is no president so crazy that fox
news would not be able to help them
maintain 40 percent support no matter
what they do no matter what they they
say and we talk about things are much
different now than they were for nixon
in the 1970s
maybe if Nixon had Fox News in the 70s
he wouldn't have had to resign maybe if
Trump didn't have something like Fox
News and the entire apparatus that's
around it maybe he would have suffered
more consequences for his harebrained
action so far that's a really scary idea
and what Fox has proven is that they can
reframe almost anything and still keep
40% of the country saying Trump's doing
a good job and that should scare the
hell out of all of us and it's it's
reminiscent of George Orwell's 1984 but
it's also reminiscent of the kind of
manufacturer of consent
outlined in George Orwell's other novel
Animal Farm which I recently reread and
many elements of what is going on
increasingly today with Fox News and
Trump and media coverage and the virus
makes me think of Animal Farm and that's
very very bad one of our sponsors today
is a game called lawgivers a turn based
political simulation game for PC iOS and
Android if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive you make election
promises to your constituents it's up to
you whether you keep those promises when
you're in office all of the laws you
pass affect your country's happiness and
safety healthcare environment you can
abolish laws that are already in place
you can ratify the Constitution you
decide if you want the government to be
a healthy democracy or authoritarian
tyranny you can be corrupt and take
bribes political assassinations are part
of the game it's nuts actually it's a
really good time it doesn't get old
because you'll never play it the same
way twice this is not some cheesy
free-to-play game it's very clear that a
lot of time went into the development it
has very positive reviews on Steam and
in the App Store's four and a half stars
or higher on all platforms go to david
pakman.com slash game which is where you
can watch the trailer download the game
for Steam iOS and Android
that's david pakman.com slash game